بحركته المعتاده حضر شيف التركيه نصرت
نهائي كاس العالم مثيرا كثيرا من الجدل
بعد خرق لقواعد فيفا في بطوله العالم
الشيخ نصرت نزل الى ارض الملعب عقبه نهايه
الكاس مزاحما لاعبي الارجنتين اثناء
تتويجهم بالكاس وملحن بالتقاط الصور معهم
نصره لم يكتفي بذلك بل الح في طلب حمل
الكاس من اللاعبين
ومقبلا اياه الامر الذي اثار حفيظه متابعي
كره القدم خصوصا ان ذلك ممنوع بحسب لوائح
فيفا كل ذلك دفع الاتحاد الدولي لكره
القدم للتحقيق بحادثه نزول اسره لارض
الملعب بعد النهائي ولمسه لكاس العالم
الامر الذي تمنعه اللوائح
يستمر الجدل حول العقوبات التي قد تلحق
بنصره كمشجع كروي لم يحترم اللوائح
القانونيه اسطوره الكاس وتاريخها مع علاء
سرحان
الا على اشخاص معينين وهم الفائزون
الحاليون به او السابقون كذلك زعماء الدول
لهذه الكاس سيره طويله واسطوريه بدات قبل
نحو اثنين وتسعين عاما كاس النصر كان
الاسم الاول لكاس العالم الذي حمله معه
رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم فيفا جول
ريميان من فرنسا الى الاوروغواي في اول
بطوله اجريت هناك وفازت بها الدوله
المستضيفه الكاس الغالي على عشاق الكره
انتقلت من اسمها الاول الى الاسم الجديد
تكريما للرجل الذي امن بفكره بطوله عالميه
تجمع اعظم اللاعبين ليكون اسمه عليها بدءا
من كاس العالم عام 1950 في البرازيل في
عام
1974 تم استبداله كاس جوندريادي اخر صممه
الايطالي سيلفو جازاجا ليكون نسخه جديده
ما زالت حتى اليوم تحافظ على القها كل
اربع سنوات ويشتاق لها محبوا البطوله هذه
الكاس الشهيره اصبحت بعد سنوات ترمم بيد
رجل عربي مغربي اسمه احمد ايه سيدي الذي
ساهم في عمليه صيانتها في اخر خمس بطولات
عالميه
[موسيقى]
انا رياضي ينضم الى الزميل العزيز نايف
سجين صباح العربيه نورنا طول المونديال
مستمر يسعد صباحك اهلا بك مش لابس ارجنتين
اليوم الحمد لله
يسعد صباحك سهام طيب خلاص احتفلنا وخلصنا
طيب حضر لك فيها السنه كلها طيب نايف
نصرت نزلنا الملعب ازعج اللاعبين وازعج
مين ميسي شخصيا وحمل الكاس وقبل الكاس
وخرق قواعد الفيل وتحدث عن لوائح الفيفا
ممنوعات
نشرح للمشاهدين ما هي قواعد فيفا او لماذا
است- فيفا من هذا التصرف في وسط البيان
اعاده قبل قبل المباراه النهائيه يكون
فيها اجتماعي يجمع جميع الاطراف تحدد همم
قائمه بالاسماء تمثل جميع من يحق لهم
الدخول سواء من همم المنتخبين وايضا ال-
همم المنظمين هؤلاء يتم منحهم بطاقات خاصه
للدخول الى ارضيه الملعب ولا يسمح لاي شخص
اخر للدخول نهائيا همم الملعب في يوم
المباراه ينقسم الى قسمين قسم همم تحت
تنظيم ومسؤوليه اللجنه المحليه وقسم تحت
مسؤوليه فيفا اللجنه المحليه تكون عاده
مسؤوله عن المدرجات ومسؤوله عن المنطقه
الخارجيه للملعب وفيفا مسؤول عن ارضيه
الملعب لذلك لو لاحظت في بيان فيفا هو ذكر
انه سيكون هناك تحقيق داخلي ما يعني ان من
يتحمل المسؤوليه كامله هي
هو هي من سمحت لن نصت همم بالدخول ايضا
فيفا سهام يحترم همم اوقات احتفالات
اللاعبين ودائما لا يشارك اي لاعب الاعب
افاد عائلته المقاربين وجود نصرت في هذا
المكان ضائق اللاعبين انفسهم وايضا همم
فيفا دائما هو المثل الاعلى لجميع
الاتحادات وجميع المنظمات الرياضيه وفيفا
وفي دائما انه الافضل في التنظيف يعني
عندما يقوم شخص باختراق همم بروتوكول
لتنظيم همم كاس العالم هذا امر مسيء لفيفه
يعني خلينا مثلا هيك نفهم اكثر الصوره
يعني نصره له باللحم له بتقطيع له بالملح
وهذه الحركه الشهيره هو هو كغيره من الناس
ومنهم انا ربما يعني غير مدركين غافلين عن
بروتوكولات فيفا هل هذا سيغفر له ام ان
القانون لا يحمي المغفلين
طبعا
نادي دعينا نتحدث انه نسخت هذه ليست اول
حادثه هو سبق واحتفل مع نادي ريال مدريد
بذات الطريقه في دوري ابطال اوروبا ولكن
ما ينطبق في الاتحاد الاوروبي لا ينطبق في
فيفا فيفا لديه قواعد صائمه ولا يسمح لاي
شخص في الدخول في ارضيه الملعب او
الاحتفال لا يحق لنصره مثل لا يحق لاشخاص
كتب ايضا نصره داخل الملعب ببطاقه فيفي اي
بي وهذه البطاقه تضع له حدود في الملعب
للتحقق دخول الى ارضيه الملعب هذا امر
مخالف وحسب التحقيقات فيفا الان طلب همم
تسجيلات الكاميرات ليتاكد كيف دخل الى
صوته من اين دخل وحتى همم تدرسها الاداره
القانونيه في حاله رغبتها في التقدم لشكوى
لدى السلطات همم القطريه بما ان الحادثه
حصلت في قطر ولكن لو نصرت يتبع الى
المنظومه الرياضيه مباشره التي يحاول
الامر الى لجنه الانضباط وستكون هناك
عقوبات في حقه وقد يكون هناك مانع كامل
لنصره كما فعلت الجمعيه همم الامريكيه
ابحث عن خصوصيه كاس العالم
يتحدث عن الخصوصيه كاس العالم كاس العالم
همم كما ذكرنا قبل قليل هو من اكثر من 50
عام هو نسخه وحيده فقط ليس لها نسخه اخرى
هذه الكاس لا تخرج الا كل اربع سنوات في
يوم النهائي
وتكون بعهده في تطوال الاربع سنوات حتى
توضع على همم همم
منصه التتويج همم ويمنح لحظتها الحق
للمنتخب الفائز ولكن سهام بعد نهايه
المباراه مباشره يتم سحب النسخه الاصليه
واعطاء المنتخب الفائز نسخه طبق الاصل
لذلك هذه يعني تمثل بالنسبه لفيفا امر
يعني امر خط احمر لفيفا ان يقوم احد بلمس
الكاس حتى انا يعني عندما
الكاس تذهب في جوله او دائما تكون مغلقه
بالزجاج مانع وايضا حتى موظفين فيفا ليس
كلهم لهم الحق في لمسها
الموظفين المسؤولين على لمس الكاس يرتدون
قفازات همم خاصه لذلك يمثل امر مهم
بالنسبه لي فيفا وايضا اكثر ما اساء فيفا
الحركه التي قام بها نصره وتعامل مع الكاس
كقطعه من اللحم هذا امر كم مسيء جدا فيفا
انت محسوم يعني يسمح لك ما يومنا على غيرك
شكرا جزيلا يا نايف فقط مذكر انه الشاف
نصرت بسبب واقعه مونديال سيمنع من نهائي
كاس امريكا المفتوحه بسبب ما فعله في
مونديال قطر شكرا جزيلا لك نايف ثقيل
وكمان نذكر بالصور اللي انتشرت للشيخ نصرت
صار في كثير من السخريه على السوشيال
ميديا نشروا صوره الشيف نصرت بجانب صوره
ميسي لما كان نايم وحامل الكاس قد ايه
يعني واضح انه انه كثير كان ملزق فيه بس
على فكره نصر الدفع عن حاله بهذه الواقعه
ونشر صوره لا اله مع ميسي ب 2018 بمطعمه
هون في دبي وكتب انه حتى ميسي يعرف طريقه
سلطه فبالتالي انه يعني مسي على شو عم
تتكبر عليك لحظه
كان ميسي اكيد ما يعرف نصره بشكل شخصيه
ولكن صراحه هي دعايه مجا نصرت ولازم يدفع
الثمن على هذه الدعايه المرجانيه فعلا كاس
العالم له احترام وله تقديره وخصوصيه
اللاعبين في هذه المناسبه انه فقط ينزلوا
مع عائلاتهم الاشخاص المقربين معهم حتى
انا سمعت انه قصص انه رؤساء الدول من نوع
من المشاركه في التقاط الصوره الجماعيه مع
منتخب الارجنتين لانه البرتوكون يمنعهم من
ذلك فما بالك انه شيف مهما كانت بس بصراحه
يقطع لحم ودخله في الملايين ما هو اي شيء
ههه